[Music]
Welcome to our final session for
Friday yeah I I guess we go from
fracking to Dodd franking in our final
session right from constructive to
destructive so we wanted to talk about
the dodf Frank Bill the title of the
session here is the economic and
political significance of the Dodd Frank
act and in three years we've had the
results of that massive regulation of
the banking industry and we have three
excellent panelists to comment on that
here we have the Dodd Frank bill as many
of you know
2,319 pages
long and I don't think it's that
spellbinding Pros that an melany was
wanting us to put forth uh and attack
Hollywood with the dod franking bill is
very important though the content of
that act has enormous impact on American
society Regulators are charged not
Congress but The Regulators charged with
making new law making new regulations
these have dramatic impact contrary in
many ways to the founders if you look at
James Madison he talked often about the
importance of having clear and
predictable
laws for a stable and prosperous Society
clear and predictable laws that isn't
what we have of course with Dodd Frank
and also the whole idea of Outsourcing
power to unelected officials we have
three panelists here who are going to do
a fine job of explaining the dodf Frank
bill and the consequences of it we have
our first panelist Jee
Epstein Jee writes for Barons and has
been doing so for over 20 years his
column is called economic beat he
started the column almost 20 years ago
Gan also has an important book econos
spinning is the name of it econos
spinning subtitled how to read between
the lines when the media manipulate the
numbers the book was published in 2006
is still available and before joining
Barons Jean worked for 13 years at the
New York Stock Exchange mainly as a
senior Economist uh Jean has taught
economics at the City University of New
York and also St John's
University he holds an master's degree
in economics from the new school and
also a bachelor's in history from
brandise University Jean has made
numerous appearances on Fox news CNBC
and the BBC television network and has
lectured around the world the title of
Jean's topic today is what caused the
crisis welcome
Jean so are we uh up and running with my
first slide yeah go ahead want the title
up there uh first of all uh let me
apologize for the somewhat rough
language uh crapitalism is my uh my uh
neologism for crony capitalism and uh I
think it works well uh the uh the
language is not going to get any
filthier than that so uh so rest assured
it's going to be fine this is actually
the second time I've been hosted by
Hillsdale College uh a beacon of freedom
and learning the the first time I
actually went out to Hillsdale and was
delighted to meet with the students it
would only be for Hillsdale College that
I would agree to do a 19-minute version
uh of a a talk I've delivered a number
of times that takes usually about 50 55
minutes it helps I believe that really
the causes of uh the failure of
capitalism the causes of the Great
Recession are pretty easy pretty simple
pretty straightforward I would say by
analogy that I could debate I could
respectfully debate a lot of people on
the causes of the Great Depression the
causes of the Great Recession however
the financial bubble are uh much simpler
the evidence is so
overwhelming that if we were to debate
the issue it would really be pretty much
around the margins I also maybe want to
save my colleagues the trouble who about
talking about Dodd Frank by pointing out
very simply that Christopher Dodd and
Barney Frank who co-authored the bill
were clearly major crony capitalist
players in the game and so this would
almost be like a calling a bill to
promote free markets the marks and Lenin
Bill to promote free markets it's really
totally ironic uh it's almost all you
have to know but they will Enlighten you
I'm sure well let me go forward and just
uh yeah I'm pressing next and it's not
working
next and next
sorry no yeah next okay yeah we know
what the greatest Great Recession was
the longest and deepest contraction of
the US economy since the Great
Depression of the 1930s the rate of
unemployment nearly doubled to more than
10% U now I said it's a failure of
capitalism so first let me establish
what capitalism is it's a private
enterprise system of profit and loss
profits encourage risk-taking losses
encourage Prudence very important to
stress that capitalism is not just about
profits very very importantly it's also
about loss unimpeded prices determine
profit and loss in the capitalist system
but under crony capitalism capitalism
unfortunately the system that tends to
dominate what goes on and certainly
dominates uh the housing market uh
profits stay privatized but losses are
absorbed by government prices including
the price of credit are distorted by
government intervention and economic
activity as in housing is actively
engaged in by government now uh two key
examples Tok players in our drama uh of
in uh the corpa system are Fanny May and
Freddy Mack they were government
sponsored Enterprises traded on the New
York Stock Exchange they went bankrupt
they went into receivership uh they're
beginning to get resuscitated by the
government most recently however so they
will come up now uh the two main factors
in the crony Capital system that caused
the problem the enabling Factor was the
central bank's negative interest rate
policy from 2002 to 2005 the propelling
factor that uh without with that
enabling Factor we might have had a mild
recession the propelling factor however
was the UF government's housing policy
that began in
1992 now this chart uh almost tells uh
the whole story uh it shows you the
inflation adjusted price of homes uh
from 1890 through 2011 uh it shows you
that in fact there was a big price
decline in uh in in the 1930s uh I guess
that unfortunately that uh that's the
measure uh cannot be seen but it's just
an index number and the number that it
tends to hover around is 100 uh it
begins at 100 it goes below 100 it goes
up to 100 so in fact by the way the uh
the inflation adjusted house uh price
did not rise by very much but now notice
what happened starting in 2000 um
starting just around the time that the
government's policies really began to
kick in uh there was a price spike uh
there was a price bubble uh uh we know
at least after the fact that it was a
price bubble we certainly knew even
during the fact that it was happening
the price Rose and then collapsed and
when it collapsed uh uh a lot of
mortgages went underwater a lot of
mortgages that were owned uh just with
two to 3% down payment sometimes with 1%
down payment that's think of it that's
like buying stocks on margin in
1929 uh with uh with very low down
payments and the uh the the private
sector mortgages private sector got in
late The Fanny May Freddy Mack FHA got
in early and started to push up that
bubble and then the private sector got
encouraged to get on the bandwagon they
they came in toward the top of the
bubble so that they were hit first The
Fanny May and Freddy Mack and FHA
mortgages were more toward the bottom of
the bubble so they were hit later and
that's of course a part of the myth of
what went on that we we we're supposed
to think that it was all private sector
because the private sector mortgages
were more vulnerable but in fact of
course it was all pushed by a very
conscious policy of government now what
was that policy first I want to show you
the negative interest rates of the
Federal Reserve the interest rate on
federal funds which the Federal Reserve
uh targets and minus the inflation rate
and in 2002 2003 2004 it was negative
now who in his right mind would lend
money U at a at a at a rate of interest
that's below the rate of inflation Only
The Government Can is foolish enough to
do that only the government can do that
um and so it's very clear that when if
you're borrowing money shortterm at
negative interest rates that's going to
be an enable Factor that's going to push
up the bubble now before I leave the
Federal Reserve because we want to get
to the propelling factor I want to quote
from the current fed Cham and he's soon
going to be outgoing uh Ben banki who
stated in front of a a a crowd of people
and this paper was published online that
economists who have generally
investigated the issue have generally
found that based on historical
relationships only a small portion of
the increase in house prices earlier
this decade can be attributed to the
stance of us monetary policy he's trying
to let the Federal Reserve off the hook
in other words and he's doing that by
the way because he was present at the
time he was uh Allan green spans uh
Federal Reserve governor who is pushing
that interest rate policy but notice I
put a number 12 there because banki
actually footnoted those economists who
investigated the issue and strangely in
the age of the internet you can look
things up very easily and you find that
that on end note two uh he says see for
example Jericho kinsky and Smiths two
economists and then you read their paper
and what do they write we find that
monetary policy has significant effects
on housing investment and house prices
and that easy monetary policy designed
to Stave off perceived risk of deflation
in
20024 has contributed to the Boom in the
housing market in 2002 and 2005 we live
in such a bided society that even in the
age of the internet our Federal Reserve
chairman has uh the uh the uh the the
hut
uh that's a Yiddish word you probably
have heard it uh to actually make a
statement s and and Source it and then
it turns out that the source said
exactly the opposite of what he was
claiming uh so that's that's the
intellectual environment in which we
live it's you know my God as a columnist
I would have had to go to the library to
look that article up it's very easy to
find it online uh so let's leave the
Federal Reserve and talk about what else
happened the propelling factor now this
is a quote from a guy named Ragu Rajan
um who who uh actually was very preent
about the bubble uh and uh he's in a
movie called Inside Job an Oscar winning
film that was truly uh terrible
misquoted Ragu Rajan but Ragu Rajan I
think set the tone when he talked about
the role of the private sector he said
the banking sector did not decide out of
the goodness of its heart to extend
mortgages to poor people politicians did
that and they would have taken great
umbrage if the regulator stood in the
way of more housing credit I mean that
too says it all in a way obviously it
was not a failure of Regulation they
would have the the government wanted
this to happen and they were going to
stop any regulator who prevented it uh
now uh this is a little long slightly
long quote but it's 1992 it set the
stage it it was the Housing Community
Development act um which launched the
situation and notice what they're saying
that the purpose of the affordable
housing goals is to facilitate the
development in both Fanny May and Freddy
Mack those two crony capitalist organiz
ganizations of an ongoing business
effort that will be fully integrated
into their products cultures and
day-to-day operations to service the
mortgage financing needs of low and
moderate income persons restal
minorities and inner city residents now
again those people were the ones who
were truly shafted they they were prayed
upon by the government um you cannot
blame them uh for being told that for
practically no down payment and all you
have to do literally in certain cases is
provide food stamps uh the food stamps
you get as Financial backing and then
you're given a house to own uh they were
fooled by the government they were
fooled mainly by Bill Clinton I asked
somebody who wrote a book about about
the situation who do you think should is
the most coupable who do you think is
the most indictable uh over this
situation you know because when the when
the Academy Award was run by was won for
the inside job by a guy name I forget
his first name his last name is Ferguson
he said you know nobody's been indicted
yet well she said Bill Clinton probably
because when Bill Bill Clinton talked
about how this is not going to cost
taxpayers a dime that he wanted the
homeowner should rate push to an
all-time high by the end of the century
he set goals for for HUD to to impose on
Fanny May and Freddy Mack um this was
his dream and again Bill Clinton simply
did not know what profit and loss were
all about he did not know what he was
doing but hopefully he could gain wisdom
about it now and apologize which not
going to do now I just that's that's the
price uh this chart shows the the same
price chart and then the rise in the
homeowners rate just showing that that
that that's that goal of Clinton's was
what was pushing up the bubble um the uh
the red uh the red line uh yeah I'm
sorry yeah the red line is the home
ownership rate which went up and then
now has fallen and the and the blue line
is that same price bubble but of course
in a way if a better chart would be to
show the the number of of of mortgages
with a down payment of 3% or less that
exploded and that Fanny May and Freddy
Mack were buying uh now uh this is Paul
Krugman uh who you may have heard of uh
I want to set up a St a quote of his and
then point out what really went on he's
talking about the right the rights
answer is to claim not just the
government did it but it caused the
crisis by its attempts to reduce
inequality exclamation point it's kind
of a master PR stroke in an evil way
well the government did do it and they
and they were are concerned about
inequality this is President Bush who
ped picked up the ball from uh from
President Clinton the goal is everybody
who wants to own a home has got a shut
of doing so that's everybody you know
doesn't matter how much you earn U the
home ownership rate is about is down to
about 65% in this country it's about
stable mostly of course it's among older
people the problem is he said that we
have a call have what we call a home
ownership Gap in America you know so
indeed President Bush was concerned
about in inequality of home ownership a
amazing realization for uh Paul Krugman
the unthinkable that a Republican
president can talk in that this way by
the way uh to George W Bush's credit
this has not been promoted very much but
in his Memoir about his administration
he has admitted that he made an
egregious mistake I actually haven't
read the complete passage so I don't
know if you recognizes that he picked up
the ball from Bill Clinton and pushed
all this but he is at least owned up to
a little bit to what he did uh now he
says he's proud to report that Fanny May
has heard the call and as I understand
it's about so again Fanny May and Freddy
Mack were called upon uh to create these
mortgages and to push them and then the
private sector got on the bandwagon the
private sector by the way who got their
arms Twisted in different ways as well
but they were in it for the money they
were part of the crony capitalist system
too Angelo Millo uh by the way was a was
if you've ever heard of him the head of
countrywide uh I don't don't think the
man really knew anything much about
mortgages he spoke at Harvard uh once
and he talked about how it's very nice
that 80% of those people who are being
given these mortgages are paying them
back he was talking about a 20% default
rate and if he knew anything about
mortgages he would knew that the
interest rate was just not covering that
default rate so indeed I don't let them
off the hook well I'm going to get into
D deregulation how much more time do I
have six months I do okay well that's
not bad um well uh d regulation did it
that's the argument that deregulation
did it uh the uh it there's no question
there's no question that had the
government told the banking system
you've got to load up on Equity you've
got to you've got we we you need a much
bigger cushion for all the risks that we
are forcing you we are persuading you to
take that there wouldn't the they would
not have been a banking crisis that is
true we could call it a sin of omission
on the part of the government uh that
that was not a failure of deregulation
because the government the Federal
Reserve had the power to say that to the
banks you need more cushion you need
more Equity um in your balance sheet in
order to protect yourself but that's
exactly the opposite of what Chris Dodd
and Barney Frank and Bill Clinton and
George W bush wanted they wanted the
banks to be issuing these mortgages but
this gu now when you talk about
deregulation which is what most of our
liberal friends are going to are going
to tell you what inside job is all about
then what did deregulation consist of
the El elimination of Regulation Q which
was simply uh the uh the uh the limit on
interest rates that Banks could charge
that was a good thing Banks had to pay
more interest rates because when
inflation hit they had to they had they
had to pay a higher rate of interest in
order to be competitive the elimination
of restrictions on Branch Banking that
was also a good thing it's little known
fact that for the first first 100 150
years of the Republic it was very
difficult for a bank to Branch with
another bank that was state laws this
was another part of the crony Capital
system a bank a local bank liked that
kind of protection Banks uh enjoyed it
because then they had a local Monopoly
it made them very vulnerable it created
a lot of banking crisis because if a
bank is just dependent on the local
wheat market for all its loans or the
local economy then it's then it's very
vulnerable but the banking system was
more or less in in League with the state
and they uh and they enjoyed that Banks
would naturally branch and diversify
their risk so there was a limit uh the
lifting of the elimination of
restrictions on Branch Banking that
helped that that helped stabilize the
system but then there was also the
partial elimination of glass steal
restriction on Commercial banks
affiliating with investment Banks that's
often raised as an issue and that too is
absurd well let me try the next uh the
partial repeal of glass steagle uh it
said which it kept Wall Street and
mainstream Banks walled off from each
other and this allowed FDIC insured
Banks whose deposit were guaranteed to
engage in highly Risky Business it all
the also it was C clearly absurd the
idea that glass deagle made any
difference at all um we wish that the
banks had done more of investment
banking what is Investment Banking it's
a relatively low-risk practice of of
underwriting stocks and bonds uh if they
had done more of it it would have helped
and in fact the partial repeal of glass
deagle helped stabilize the system
because it allowed mergers between maril
Lynch and Bank of America it it it it uh
it it allowed I forget the other merger
that took place Morgan Stanley merg they
they it was actually stabilizing so this
idea of of this very highly regulated
industry uh being in any way uh uh uh
caused that in being in any way
destabilized by deregulation is simply
nonsense um and uh the uh what oh the
there's the Glam reach Bry thing was
also about uh was was the law that
permitted branching and uh and then we
have the New York Times saying the isn't
entirely blameless for one thing the
merges that encouraged left banks with
more Capital to invest some of the
capital ended up in that deluded more
subprime mortgage Market well that's
that's a very lame statement uh the
reason why the the capital ended up in
that subprime mortgage Market was
because the government was essentially
trying uh to uh to to to push the home
ownership rate to
70% a rate that it could not sustain
because it was selling mortgages to
people who couldn't afford them and when
the bubble burst and and uh and the and
prices began to fail fail those
mortgages failed by the ton and as those
mortgages failed by the ton it upended
the banking system and it caused a it it
it caused a a a freezing of credit which
then spilled over into other sectors of
the economy and then we had the Great
Recession again the the broad outlines
of the story
uh of any economic downturn that I have
ever read about uh there are few
economic downturns where the facts and
the and and the basic uh stage setting
the basic very explicit involvement of
two presidents in in this uh bubble that
burst uh it's almost I know of no
situation in economic history that is as
clear as this one I'll yield to my
colleagues now thank you
[Applause]
yeah thank you Jean for that helpful
commentary on the housing crisis our
next speaker is Nicole
galenus she's with the Manhattan
Institute she's a fellow at the
Manhattan Institute and
contributes uh writing is the editor of
City Journal she writes on Urban
economics Finance Municipal and
corporate finance and business
issues in a sense she's the answer to
that question that sometimes we
hear what can you do with a degree in
English
literature all of that she does Nicole
is a chartered financial analyst and
member of the New York Society of
Securities analysts her most recent book
is entitled after the
fall the book is subtitled saving
capitalism from Wall Street and
Washington Nicole is written for the New
York Times The Wall Street Journal the
Los Angeles Times and dozens of other
Publications she graduated from Tain
University with a bachelor's degree in
English literature she and her husband
live in
Manhattan
Nicole good afternoon thank you Bert uh
just like Jean I am a Hillsdale
recidivist so I'm happy to be back for
my my second time speaking before the
the free market forum and thank you to
Anita as well well Dodd Frank may or may
not be unconstitutional I don't want to
give away the answer because I I know
Todd hasn't spoken yet but there's a
more practical problem with the law and
that is that it doesn't work and it was
designed not to
work what was the problem that Dodd
Frank was supposed to fix it was
supposed to fix the problem of too big
to
fail it it does not do that and it will
never end too big to fail and indeed the
problem the Practical problem of laws
being designed not to work is a part of
the problem that we're seeing with
Obamacare as well Dodd Frank and
ObamaCare care have quite a bit in
common since Obamacare has been in the
news so much the last couple of weeks
I'll thread some comparisons to
Obamacare into my discussion about Dodd
Frank the two laws have several things
in common for starters as as Bert noted
both of the laws are far too long and
far too complex Dodd Frank's 849 pages
in the official legislated version of
the law Obamacare clocks in at 906 Pages
this is a new phenomenon the 1965 act
that created Medicare was 138 Pages not
906 pages on the financial side the
Securities Act of
1933 which was a Cornerstone of
financial regulation for uh five decades
and until it began to be eroded in the
1980s was just 93 p ages and the glass
steel act that Jean talked about it's
another 19 1933 law that dealt with
financial regulation that was 53 Pages
the 1934 Securities Exchange act another
part of our Depression era Financial
laws despite decades and Decades of
amendments is still only 371 Pages still
uh less than half the size of Dodd Frank
and in fact just talking about the
length of the law understates the case a
bit dodf Frank was not really a law but
as Louise Bennetts of the KO Institute
likes to say it was a set of mandates
for Regulators Dodd Frank directed
Regulators from the Federal Reserve the
FDIC controller of the currency to write
398 separate rules and so far Regulators
have written more than
18,7 189 pages of text
to to make up these these rules and
they're only 40% done moreover they have
missed the majority of the deadlines
that Congress set for them more than
three years ago when Obama uh when
President Obama signed the bill into law
it's not only rule writing that makes it
difficult to know what this law will
really do when it's it's finally being
enforced it's also bureaucracy creating
that is adding to the delay and I'll
just read you some of the new acronyms
that dodf Frank gave us we've got a new
fsoc a financial stability oversight
Council we have a new ofr the office of
financial research we have a new IAC
investor advisory committee we have a
new RAC the research and Analysis Center
we have a new f frf a financial research
fund we have a new OA a orderly
liquidation Authority we've got an Olf
as well as an OA orderly liquidation
fund we've got
omwi which is office of minority and
women inclusion actually there are
several of those now we've got uh Office
of Financial Education Office of service
member Affairs office of financial
protection for older Americans a
consumer Advisory Board and a private
education loan um budsman none of these
things existed before Dodd Frank was was
made into law so every one of these
agencies or collections of people need
someone to be in charge they need staff
and and so forth now it would be one
thing if we were going through all of
this trouble to create something that
would do the job but there's a growing
bipartisan consensus that Dodd Frank is
not working H you know don't ask me ask
the treasury secretary Jacob L went
before Congress in May and he said that
I think the challenge is now to make
sure that we know that these can work he
said about the provisions of the law the
operation issues are not insignificant
he said and then somewhat obliquely Lou
concluded that we are still determining
how to set the levels in various areas
so that in the end we'll be able to say
that too big defail has ended now this
is three years well in May it was nearly
3 years since the law had been signed
but yet the treasury secretary was still
not able to go before Congress and say
that the law was working as intended
that we had ended too big to fail you
look on the Democratic side of Congress
Elizabeth Warren the new Democratic
senator from from Massachusetts she has
announced what she calls a new glass
deagle Bill a 30 page bill for financial
regulation her doing this is a sign that
even the left thinks parts of the left
think that the law is not
working it's easy to say that and this
is true of Obamacare too that Dodd Frank
had to be very long and complicated
because we are dealing with a complex
and difficult problem and so to deal
with a complicated problem you have to
have a complicated Solution that's a
mistake there was a a book review of
Judge Richard posner's new book in The
New York Times last week and he wrote In
the book as the times quoted that uh
judges are escaping from complexity in
more complexity and he he didn't think
that was a good thing and and it's not
it was very simple to fix the problem of
2008 that too big to fail problem what
should the government have done what did
the government need to do
uh the biggest thing is has to do with
capital what is capital a financial
institution borrows a certain percentage
of the money that it holds on its
balance sheet and then it goes out in
turn and lends that money to people or
institutions or invests it in another
way but a financial firm has to have a
certain percentage of non-borrowed money
as well and that's for the same reason
that a person shouldn't borrow all of
all of theone money that they invested
in their home or in another asset if you
borrow 100% of the value of your home if
you have to sell your home suddenly and
there's a market downturn even if it
goes down 2% or 5% in
value you you have you are not able to
pay back the debt that you owe you want
to have a little bit of an equity
cushion a non-borrowed cash cushion to
give yourself a a little bit of uh
flexibility to absorb a loss that's the
same thing with a financial firm if
Financial firm borrows all of the money
uh that it has to invest in in assets if
the market of value of those assets goes
down by just a couple of percentage
points financial institution is
insolvent if it's lucky no one will
notice that it's
insolvent uh if not it's going to be
liquidated and and go out of
business having a high and a consistent
Capital requirement for financial
institutions would have done the trick
for three reasons one right now the
government's Capital requirements are
very inconsistent so if you are a
financial firm and you want to borrow
money to do what the government wants
you to do that is uh if you're a
financial firm and you are approving new
mortgages or you are lending money to
the government itself in the form of
purchasing treasury bonds the government
is very happy with these activities and
so the government says you don't have to
have a lot of non-borrowed money behind
these activities by contrast if you're
doing something that that the government
doesn't want you to do or that the
government doesn't care about you
investment in uh a private Equity
Venture you have to put a lot more uh
non-borrowed money be behind those
Investments so what does the
government's policy do by saying we want
you to invest in these things and we
will give you a break on your Capital if
you do this the government encourages
the whole financial system to make the
same mistake all at once the financial
system can withstand different companies
making different mistakes at different
times even companies going bankrupt but
it can't withstand whole financial
system effectively making the same
mistake at the same time that's what we
saw in 2008 the second reason is that if
firms had more Capital firms would be
more likely to be able to go bankrupt
without endangering the rest of the
economy you have a higher cushion for
for failures and so you can allow for
these failures without taking down the
rest of the economy and the third reason
is really just the combination of these
other two reasons if investors knew that
Banks could fail investors would be much
more careful about lending their money
to these large financial institutions
this is what Gan said about loss or the
risk of loss encouraging
Prudence lenders you large institutional
lenders that provide the money that
large Financial firms use they know that
the system still can't withstand
Financial failures they know then that
there will be bailouts in the future and
they still lend money at artificially
low rates to these these large Financial
firms so what has the government done it
didn't do that instead it it made uh it
asked Regulators to make all of these
new rules and what are the results of
this rul making just as we are learning
that Obamacare is not working the way
the president thought it would work or
the president said he thought it would
work Dodd Frank is not working the way
it's supposed to work either just take
one rule the vocal rule this was a
signature part of dodf Frank named after
the former Federal Reserve chairman Paul
vuler the rule was me was meant so that
if you're a large Financial firm and you
benefit from taxpayer subsidies like
FDIC Insurance of your deposits you were
not supposed to use that subsidy to
invest in Risky Ventures uh speculative
short-term bets in particular markets
now the first problem with this this is
it sends a very bad signal things like
FDIC Insurance are not supposed to help
Banks they're supposed to help the
customers of the banks and they're not
supposed to prohibit failure they are
supposed to facilitate failure if the
bank fails and small depositors get
their money back that makes it much
easier politically for the bank to fail
so by saying that the subsidy is
benefiting the banks not the customers
we are further muddling how to fix too
big to fail and the other problem is
that they just The Regulators just can't
figure out how to do this what is a
risky bet that should be prohibited if a
bank buys a collection of bonds because
it thinks it's going to have a customer
for those bonds next week is that
unacceptable speculation with taxpayer
money or is that just good solid
business you know if you sell apples you
buy apples because you think people are
going to buy your apples is that the
same thing or is this something that
Financial firms should not be doing so
after thousands and thousands of pages
written they still have not come up with
an enforcable version of of this this
rule uh and vulker uh chairman vulker
went on TV and he blamed the regulators
and said it shouldn't take them 3 years
to make a rule that there's still too
much regulatory overlap and you know
some of that is true but also they can't
do very much with a law that was that
was very badly
written now the bigger problem and the
problem with Obamacare too is that why
why do we have a law that is like this
the way that it is this is a symptom of
a much bigger problem the unwillingness
of either party to level with the voters
you know President Obama never said
upfront in order for everyone to have
health insurance younger healthier
people are going to have to to pay more
so that older unhealthier people are
going to have to pay less everyone is
finding out about this now and are very
surprised the the same thing is true
with Dodd Frank if we had Financial
regulation that worked if we really did
end to Big to fail the political and
economic effects would not be good in
the short term if Financial firms were
no longer too big to fail they wouldn't
be able to borrow as cheaply they
couldn't lend money to people as cheaply
so that they could purchase and
refinance
mortgages that means price housing
prices would fall if you're a young
person looking to buy a house you won't
be able to pay as much if you're looking
to sell a house uh to this foolish young
person you're going to have to sell it
for less than you expected to Obama
would not have been reelected if we had
ended too big to fail and mortgage rates
and the price of other types of credit
was as high or were as high as it should
be uh
and
another one one difference with between
Dodd Frank and ObamaCare is not a very
good difference the problem is people
can see right now that Obamacare is is
not working the way it was supposed to
if that continues and if people once
they've got their insurance through
these exchanges they find out I can't
see the doctor that I wanted to see I've
got a six month wait because the doctor
has thousands of new patients they're
going to be upset they'll be able to see
that it's not working with Dodd Frank
it's much more subtle it's hard for
people to know that an artificially
distorted Financial system is still kind
of coloring everything we do and the
long-term effects of that are not very
good we have a financial system that
continues to compete with the real
economy rather than support the real
economy because of these artificial
subsidies if you are an investor you'd
rather lend your money to a bank where
it's safe then lend your money to a a a
venture that does contain some risk
because it is not implicitly subsidized
by the government and then there are
other distortions as well far too much
of our Capital still goes into the
housing sector uh people put their
investment into their house instead of
into
into uh companies and markets that might
create more jobs might fix some of the
imbalances that we have in the economy
with Americans still consuming too much
and Chinese and other parts of the world
still producing too much these things
still exists for a lot of reasons but in
part because Dodd Frank didn't do the
job of making sure that Financial firms
are subject to free market discipline as
other types of of companies are or other
types of businesses are what's the
what's the end of all of this what
eventually would end too big to fail is
politics and good politics and people
simply not accepting another round of
bailouts whether it's two years from now
5 years from now or 10 years from now
and the party in power realizing it is
just toxic for us to continue to bail
out these large Financial firms and you
we see some of this in Congress in
addition to the Elizabeth Warren Bill
David vider Republican senator of
Louisiana has a bill to address the uh
the continuing problem of too big to
fail Savvy politicians know that this is
still a problem and it's still a
political problem and it's a it's a
vulnerability for presidential
candidates going into the next election
just as it was for the last two a good
politician who can understand and grasp
that could do very well Rick Santorum
did well in the primary not only because
of social issues in 2008 or 2012 but
because he was also the only candidate
who was talking about the problem of
Wall Street and too big to fail Mitt
Romney never even seem to notice that
people were still thinking about this
whether it's a democrat or a republican
the next time around someone who
understands that Americans are not
against capitalism they're not against
free markets they're not against rich
people they're just against a system for
large financial institutions and the
people who work there and a different
system for everybody else they
understand that that is in unfairness
it's really only Washington and Wall
Street that maybe understand that that's
not fair but they like things the way
that they are thank
you that's good thank you Nicole for
helping us understand why uh Dodd Frank
is too big to succeed maybe uh our final
speaker is Todd
zwicki and Todd is George Mason
University Foundation professor of law
at George Mason University School of Law
and George Mason has a wonderful Law
School in econ Department Hillsdale
College sends a lot of its graduates to
George Mason uh Todd is also Supreme uh
the co-editor of Supreme Court Economic
Review from 2003 to 2004 he served as
director of The Office of policy
planning at the Federal Trade Commission
he has testified over a dozen times
before Congress on issues of bankruptcy
law and Consumer Credit he's a frequent
commentator on legal and business issues
in the print and broadcast
media he also taught at Vanderbilt
University Law School Georgetown
University Law Center Boston College Law
School and Mississippi College School of
Law he is the author of over 70 articles
in leading law reviews and peer-reviewed
economic
journals Todd received his law degree
from the University of Virginia he
earned a master's degree in economics
from Clemson University and his
undergraduate degree from Dartmouth
College and he's a frequent commentator
on issues related to upholding standards
at Dartmouth College welcome Todd a
[Applause]
Wiki thanks Bert and uh unlike my two
co-panelists uh um I'm not a recidivist
but I do feel like teaching at George
Mason law school that um uh Hillsdale
has always seem like sort of our our
sister undergrad institution in U in in
some sense uh because uh we're kind of a
unique place at George Mason law school
as well and so it's a real pleasure for
me to be here and I really enjoyed both
Jean and Nicole's uh remarks which I
thought were terrific and um um uh and
and very insightful and U I agree with
pretty much all of it so my task is to
talk about Dodd Frank and the
Constitution and there are a couple
legal cases pending but rather than talk
about the legal cases I'm going to talk
about in a more conceptual sort of way
to think about do uh do Frank in the
Constitution now in Federalist 51 um my
favorite Federalist Paper um a uh a
comment so geeky that one could only uh
utter it in a room full of uh of other
professors my favorite Federalist paper
right uh uh Madison talks about the
fundamental challenge of constitutional
architecture and he says but what is
government itself but the greatest of
all Reflections on human nature if men
were Angels no government would be
necessary if angels are to govern then
neither external nor internal controls
on government would be necessary in
framing a government which is be
administered by men over men the great
difficulty lies in this you must first
enable the government to control the
governed and in the next place oblig it
to control itself a dependence on the
people is no doubt the primary control
of the government but experience has
taught mankind the necessity of
auxiliary precautions now this Insight
that Madison has you must first enable
the government to control the Govern and
in the next place oblig it to control
itself I think is the fundamental
insight into constitutional government
there is no solution to that it is
simply a tradeoff right which is that
allowing the uh uh uh government to
control the Govern basically means we
need to protect the government from
factionalism in Madison's terms right
what we would call special interest
today and to some extent we want to give
our political leaders some degree of
Independence to protect them from the
influence of uh of factions of special
interest whether majoritarian or
minoritarian but at the same time we uh
after we create Independence for that on
the other hand we've got to oblige the
government to control itself which is we
don't want to have a king who's
completely unaccountable because he'll
indulges own own preferences rather than
the reason that we have it so we create
a constitutional architecture that has
three branches composed of people
selected by different means to president
by the Electoral College two houses of
Congress selected in different ways most
importantly I think the original Senate
which was appointed by state legislators
don't get me going on uh the 17th
Amendment uh but and then the
independent Judiciary right um now and
and so the the idea is to kind of muddle
through and come up with a balance uh
between a legitimate Republican
government on one hand and
overarching tyranny and control by our
Governors on the other now Dodd Frank
takes a very clear view on this Dodd
Frank says we are coming down on the
side of allowing the governors to do
whatever they want to essentially and as
Jean uh portrayed you know and I I think
very nicely summarized what I would say
is this is based the logic of Dodd Frank
which creates these super independent
bureaucratic uh mechanisms is premised
on this particular Narrative of the
financial crisis the political narrative
that Jean described right which is that
that um the big Banks corrupted the
political system they repealed glass
steagle they allowed Branch baking they
deregulated consumer financial markets
and uh uh and uh and that sort of thing
now leave aside the fact that virtually
every single sentence of that is untrue
uh as Jean told us that's the narrative
that lies behind Dodd Frank and the
lesson they draw from it is that that
means we need to insulate all of our
political leaders all of our governors
from political oversight right and so
that's what we see sort of running
through uh Dodd Frank uh the second
thing they say is that we need to that
capitalism is inherently unstable and uh
everybody's inherently bad right the
bankers and that sort of thing so we
need to have discretion the government
needs to have discretion to chase down
the bad guys to respond to emergencies
they arise and that sort of thing the
lesson they take away from the uh the
financial crisis and we see this riddled
all throughout Dodd Frank right right uh
um we see it in the um uh the financial
stability oversight commission that
Nicole mentioned which allows uh the
government to declare certain
institutions to be systemically risky um
uh based on a very vague definition and
no articulated standards just some
degree of interconnectedness
interestingly enough um uh uh you can
challenge being called systemically
risky but you have to challenge within
30 days and in that challenge you're not
allowed to raise any statutory or
constitutional objections uh your judges
are specifically not allowed to consider
statutory constitutional objections to
being declared systemically risky we've
got the orderly liquidation Authority
which has this hair trigger process by
which if you're declared insolvent by
the government you have 24 hours not
just to sue but to get a judge to uh um
to to stop the process and if you if
anybody and it has to be done in secret
and if anybody hears about it you can go
to jail if you tell anybody that the
government is shutting you down and
putting you into a a liquidation right
again no statutory constitutional issues
of course the great uh uh example of
this is the cfpb um Professor Elizabeth
Warren's uh uh uh you know creation a uh
a uh it's it's inside the Federal
Reserve but it's not subject to the
Federal Reserve they have single
director appointed a five-year term
removable only for cause uh they got a
guaranteed budget they get 12% of the
expenditures of the Federal Reserve
every year no questions asked they don't
have to go to Congress for
Appropriations give you a sense in 2013
that's $597 million that are given to
the cfbb no questions asked and you'll
be happy to know that when the
government shut down a few weeks ago the
cfpb just kept on trucking uh because
they don't get Appropriations on the
government so uh so the cfpb was still
open when the government shut down give
you a sense of $597 million that's
doubled the size of the Federal Trade
Commission which does is one of our
major antitrust authorities and also
does the rest of consumer protection uh
uh for the government now to be sure and
I don't want to leave aside the fact uh
rent seeking uh by big Banks is a big
problem um I I I agree uh with that I
mean uh I know I couldn't go up to
Washington and get $700 billion doll of
taxpayer money uh and I don't think
anybody else here could right I don't
think that was the explanation for
deregulation though uh and I certainly
don't think that uh um unconstrained
government power is the response to that
so instead so let's look back and an
examp
the progressive myth about uh about why
we deregulate the financial system and
the rest of the economy in the 70s and
that'll help us to understand once we
understand the reality what really
happened so what really happened well we
know what happened is we created the uh
uh the modern administrative State uh
beginning with the Progressive Era
excelling during the New Deal era and it
looked just like the kind of dream world
that's created by Dodd Frank right a
bunch of unaccountable bureaucrats
running around running the economy
without uh any you know just doing what
they thought was the right thing to do
well what happened well we found by the
1970s uh that our bureaucrats were
inflicting Upon Us economic stagnation
uh declines in entrepreneurship uh Japan
was eating our lunch does this uh
history ring a bell with anybody because
it doesn't ring a bell with anybody in
Washington uh so uh so at least some
people uh remember what this was and and
also we discovered that uh interest
groups um um a capture theory of
government was was called where
basically manipulating the bureaucracies
and the you know the halls of government
for their own for their own purposes so
the response which was led originally by
Ted Kennedy and Jimmy Carter was to
begin deregulating uh and uh updating
some of these administrative agencies we
abolished the Civil Aeronautics board
the Interstate Commerce Commission we
reformed the FTC and those uh and those
sorts of things uh and uh and that's
that's the real history right which is
unaccountable government bureaucrats
ruin the economy is what I thought we
learned during the 19 1970s Dodd Frank
however as is as if they took everything
that they ever learned froze it in Amber
in
1974 right and then thought it out again
in 2008 as if they didn't they didn't
learn anything that happened during the
period in the intervening period so I
think of Dodd Frank as the Revenge of
Richard Nixon right Nixon coming back
from the grave to create an
administrative U uh agency right um the
other thing that we discovered is this
this Thicket this web of comp Lex
bureaucratic uh uh
behavior um is really kind of that
that's in in in statutes that are thick
and
complicated as we've been talking about
are really that's the engine of crony
capitalism in the economy right the
engine of crony capitalism is discretion
the ability of the government to pick
winners and losers and so for instance a
paper just came out from the Marcus
Center recently that noted that your
likelihood of uh whether or not you got
bailout money as a bank was very
strongly related to how much lobbying uh
what your lobbying expenditures were in
Washington for instance right when
you've got these kind of Thicket of
rules it's not the little guys it's not
the small startup business who can weave
their way through this Thicket it's the
big guys the connected guys the guys can
hire the lawyers and the lobbyists in
order to uh to get it done why is the
tax code so long it's not because
special interests are arguing for lower
rates right the tax code is that thick
because they're lobbying for loopholes
right
and that's what I think is interesting
about uh Nicole's um uh observation
about Dodd Frank being a system that's
set up to fail right let me give you an
example it has to do with um qualified
mortgages now qualified mortgages is a
rule that was put out by the uh by the
uh the cfpb completely nonsensical rule
because it doesn't get to the underlying
point that that Gene mentioned which was
the lack of equity that people have in
their homes but it was what it's
supposed to do is identify safe
mortgages based on ability to pay so it
looks at things like what your income uh
uh you know your your how what percent
of your income is going to pay your debt
what your FICO score is and that sort of
thing right so over here you got one
logic right which is a consumer
protection logic of not making loans
that people can't afford right FICO
score income that sort of thing over
here though the cfpb has another
Authority which is the authority to
enforce Fair Landing laws right uh uh
and they've said that they want to use
disperate impact which is that if you
see a different uh sort of disparity for
race or sex or something like that we're
going to assume that you're
discriminating now just assume for the
sake of argument um that say FICO scores
have some relationship to demographic
impact right so that if you only make
loans to people above a certain FICO
score there's some possibility that your
lending pool is going to end up being
out of compliance with what they think
of in terms of uh uh uh dispert impact
you follow the point how can you make
alone in that world right they they've
basically set up a system where if you
make only qualified mortgages you're
exposing yourself to liability over here
right how can you do that you can only
do that if you know how to send the
right guys and the right lawyers and the
right lobbyists into the cfpb and
massage them right to figure out how to
make this work oh and you'll be happy to
know that one of the guys who help set
up the cfpb has in fact Now set up a
Consulting business that'll tell you how
to make qualified mortgages uh if
anybody uh if anybody uh uh needs that
uh information he can tell you how to
weave through that uh through that
Thicket right so what let's talk about
the fpb for a uh uh uh for a few minutes
now to reconcile this balance we've kind
of uh uh uh that Madison identifies
we've come to two different ways of
creating bureaucratic structures uh uh
that are more or less uh constitutional
right the first is the executive agency
an executive agency is an agency uh uh
where basically the the a cabinet
department where the secretary serves at
the pleasure of the President right so
if you don't like what they're doing you
think they're doing a bad job the
president can just fire them the
mechanism is political accountability to
the President right the other thing
we've come up with is an independent
agency and this has an uneasy fit within
the Constitution we've kind of gotten
used to it this is an agency that is
headed by a uh a bipartisan commission
usually like five people right mix of
Democrats and Republicans subject to
congressional oversight uh and what we
have there instead of accountability is
sort of internal deliberation right the
ability of a bipartisan committee for
for for people to descent to create a
record for judicial review uh uh and
that sort of thing now what's
interesting about the cfbb it is neither
it is neither it is neither an executive
agency even though it has a single
director uh because the president can't
remove him he serves for a five-year
term removable uh uh for cause um to be
confirmed by the Senate now the amazing
thing is really the only check that
Congress had was the ability to confirm
the director of the cfpb but as you may
remember that was even too much because
because the president did an illegal
recess appointment of the cfpb director
uh and that's a case that's going to be
heard uh uh in in the Supreme Court it's
also not an independent agency because
there's only one director right it
doesn't have Congress has no budgetary
oversight uh to be able to uh to do it
it's not accountable to the Fed so it's
not really a bureau within the FED
because the FED can't review the things
that the cfpb does uh and this one guy
the director but gets to uh to appoint
every single person within the agency uh
unilaterally right in fact I've called
it an independent agency inside another
independent agency right inside the uh
inside the FED um and so what has the
record been of the cfpb so far well I'll
give you one example you may have seen
the Wall Street Journal yesterday
talking about the this uh uh thing
they're doing with auto dealers uh which
is auto dealers are specifically um uh
Exempted from cfpb's oversight a pure
special interest car Val but a very
clear one in the uh in the statute
nevertheless even that little portion of
the universe is too much for the cfpb to
keep their hands off of so what they're
doing is they're going to the banks that
Supply money to auto dealers to make
loans and basically telling the banks we
are going to hold you responsible for
any discriminatory lending patterns
based on disperate impact that we see
the the auto dealers making with money
that you supply to them right they're
basically turning the banks into private
enforcers of the federal government now
how can they do that well that's the
reality that we live in right which is
that the banks are in bed with the
government they basically work at the uh
suffrage of of the government and so as
a result that's actually working which
is that that's actually working the
banks are cracking down on the auto
dealers who are who are doing them and
that's what we start to see in this this
world of Dodd Frank right in a world in
which it's impossible to comply with all
of the laws in a world with a
fundamentally unworkable Statute in the
way Nicole described
it becomes the the true world of crony
capitalism right as Nicole said despite
all the Bluster nobody really believes
that Dodd Frank gets rid of too big
defil um the as far as we could tell
there's not been a lot of studies on
this but as far as we could tell the two
big defil subsidy is still there which
means that uh big Banks can raise money
in capital markets uh cheaper and get a
competitive advantage against small
Banks the pure regulatory cost of Dodd
Frank um is choking off uh a small banks
that basically to hire another dozen or
two lawyers at JP Morgan Chase is a
rounding error to hire one hire another
lawyer or two for a community bank with
12 employees is a big hit on the bottom
line and so what we're seeing is
Community Banks are going under in large
part or merging in large part just
because of the regulatory cost of Dodd
Frank not to mention as I saying a lot
of them are just simply leaving the uh
the mortgage lending market for instance
recognizing that you can't make a uh uh
loans in this kind of environment in
which you can't predict your uh your
liability the cfbb also has the power to
go after um uh unfair deceptive and
abusive practices or products um not
defined anywhere uh unfair and deceptive
have historic definitions in the FTC but
it's not clear whether they're going to
follow abusive is a completely new term
that nobody knows what it means and the
director of the cfpb has said I am not
going to do rule making on uh abuse Ive
I'm going to uh uh Define it by
enforcement right which means you will
find out after the fact whether or not
we think that what you've done is uh uh
abusive right um and that's the kind of
world that we live in so who who who
succeeds in that world obviously the big
Banks right obviously the big banks are
the ones who can uh hire the lawyers and
the lobbyists to be able to work through
the system they're the ones benefited by
the twoo big defail Subs I think one of
the great ironies of Dodd Frank is going
to actually end up promoting
uh consolidation of the banking industry
and making the twoo big to fail Banks
even too much bigger uh to fail right
and Washington likes this as well right
uh think for example back to the auto
bailout and I don't know if you remember
this but one of the things uh during the
Chrysler bout basically what happened
was uh there were uh they plundered the
secure creditors in Chrysler you may
remember well a lot of those Bonds were
held by big Banks do we think big Banks
just usually roll over uh when a company
wants to take them to the take them to
the hoop and bankruptcy no why did they
do you think it has anything to do with
the fact that they were on welfare from
the government because they give them
tens of billions of dollars of bailout
money I think so uh yeah I mean and
that's basically what we see in Dodd
Frank is this insinuation of the
government in turning if you want to
take the auto dealers uh example as a
good example turning the private sector
turning the banks into arms of the
federal government to basically do
off-balance sheet sort of uh uh social
engineering right and that's basically
the way that this works you may not know
for instance in the auto bailouts
there's a specific provision that
basically said if Chrysler met a certain
uh um uh
uh goals for green cars Fiat would
automatically get more stock in the
company right they're basically engaging
in environmental planning through the
process of the the balum so my remaining
time let me what what what can we do
about this what can we do about this
well one of the things I would say is
first I was very disappointed and
disheartened by the complete
lack of of um of spine by the Judiciary
during the financial crisis uh and it
makes me very nervous about the future
of the rule of law in the country that
they that the uh that even the Supreme
Court refused to stop the auto Ballout
um and later went back and vacated the
opinion but uh but I have very little
confidence of the Judiciary to stand up
for for the rule of law in a time of a a
financial crisis I think secondly
politics um is uh is is is not likely to
help either uh Rah Emanuel said it best
right never let a good crisis go to
waste the purpose of the rule of law is
to constrain politicians in special
interest and what we saw during the
financial crisis was basically rampant
overrunning the rule of law for whom the
benefit of the politicians and uh uh in
the uh in in the special interest I
think one of the things we might have to
think about is uh um uh more dramatic
constitutional type reforms perhaps it
perhaps it's higher Capital requirements
perhaps in the world of the second best
we have to think about breaking up the
big Banks if we think as I think may be
possible that we can't stop bouts that
the political temptation of bouts may
just be too great let me say the final
thing then about what this uh two two
final things which is I think that when
it comes to this inter relationship of
corporate of big business and uh uh B
big uh and big government I think this
is what obamanomics really is it's not
really so much about socialism is it
about corporatism right it's big
government big business and Big labor in
bed together carving up the economy uh
and distributing it the way that they
like turning big business into an
instrumentality to deliver Social
Services as we see with uh Banks and uh
uh and and that sort of thing I think
the final thing that bothers me about
all this is that one of the things we
learned from this experience I think
it's just hard to put the genie back in
the bottle which is when we allow
breaches of the rule of law and the
Constitution during the crisis under a
claim perceived necessity we don't roll
it back after we didn't roll it back
after the Great Depression and we didn't
roll it back after the financial crisis
uh what happens is the politicians as we
see in Dodd Frank swoop in and they
basically consolidate it Dodd Frank
isn't a law it's 2400 pages of codified
discretion and basically telling
bureaucrats to do whatever they want to
it may look like a law but it's not a
law there are certain people who benefit
from that and certain people who don't
and certain people who benefit from that
are going to dig in and protect it
[Applause]
thanks
good thank you for that help on the
Constitutional aspects of DOD Frank and
recognizing also the parallels between
the crisis atmosphere and the Great
Depression and the expansion of the
federal government there and similarly
the expansion of the government under
the housing crisis with the Dodd Frank
Bill how much time do we have Anita um
we have a good 15 plus minutes 15 plus
minutes good we have time for questions
are Gina and Laura ready yes good we
have questions as moderator I have only
one
request that your question be shorter
than the
answer thank
you I didn't hear any of the panelists
talk a whole lot I don't think about the
role of the credit rating cartel of
uh standard pores Moody Fitch and I
wonder if you could comment on the the
role that they played issuing all these
AAA ratings to steaming piles of
subprime junk uh for which they've been
sued over and going forward whether you
think uh there should be a role whether
we even need credit rating agencies and
if so
what how they should be paid what kind
of relationship they should have with
the institutions whose stuff they are
rating and and a way to somehow make
credit rating work better than it
apparently worked during uh this
crisis I'd like to comment uh to that uh
very pertinent question in the longer
version of my speech I mentioned that of
course uh this uh was a part of the
crony Capital system imagine that uh
Consumer Reports
uh is suddenly becomes uh the
government's arm for approving whatever
you can buy and uh that uh whatever you
uh let's say if a bank is going to give
you any credit uh toward a purchase that
uh it has to be approved by Consumer
Reports uh and so Consumer Reports then
becomes the government's designated uh
credit uh Raider and then of course
imagine on top of that that the
government has a particular stake in
your uh buying certain goods and
services like uh let's say by analogy uh
they want you to buy things for your new
home because they've been encouraging
you uh to buy new homes uh now of course
what that's exactly what did happen
Senate and po the other credit Raiders
uh became uh the government designated
uh approved credit rating agency so that
it was therefore impossible for you and
me to get into the business because uh
we we're not government approved that
was part of the crony Capital system uh
when not government approved and then on
top of that anybody who worked for the
credit there were in fact some people
who worked for the credit rating
agencies as indeed there were people who
worked for Fanny and Freddy who were
pretty appalled at what was going on but
uh you know what are you going to do
become a whistleblower uh when Barney
Frank and Chris Dodd and Bill Clinton
and later George W bush are going to
come down and are G to have your head if
you don't give this junk uh AAA rating
uh so uh obviously uh the answer course
to the question is we don't want credit
Raiders to become a part of the credit
uh the chrony capital system by the way
I don't think it matters too much about
who pays for the credit rating uh
because obviously if if we have a free
market in Raiders U and I can even
imagine a market in which we're not
especially interested U certainly hedge
funds um funds with a lot of money are
going to do their own rating and their
own evaluation uh but uh there could be
a market for it just like there's a
market for Consumer Reports probably
consumer reports and other consumer
Raiders would be more far more dominant
if we didn't imagine uh that uh that the
federal government is doing some of that
evaluation for us uh we know it's not
really we know it's basically in bed uh
with its own uh cronies but indeed it's
just it was it was it was an important
part of the story uh but fits very well
uh with uh the the simple narrative that
this was uh capitalism capitalism at
work but getting back again to your
question do we want credit Raiders well
does the market want credit rers
probably it does leave it to the market
uh certainly there's a long tradition of
people who evaluate things for us for
different institutions and post those
ratings and stand by them I certainly
think that you know we we we are told
that we're too dumb to buy medical care
that we need these surrogate who are
supposedly smarter than we are who are
buying it for us and obviously wasting a
lot of our money in the process and
buying a lot of things for us that we
don't really need uh so I I think that
clearly maybe we're better than they a
little smarter than they about what we
really want to spend but certainly uh
there would be I think you and I should
start a web service called second
opinion.com you go to a doctor then then
you want you do want a second opinion
you want another evaluator it's very
very very natural we live it one of the
glories of our society is that we have
uh we we we have certification uh we
need to buy Brands we need to trust
Brands we need evaluators the market
sorts that out very well uh without
government intervention thank you Nicole
do you have to add or yeah I would just
say one of the reasons that many
investors were so intent on getting
these AAA ratings was that they they had
to have the financial
institutions could hold less Capital
against instruments that had the AAA
rating so another false incentive to
look at the rating and not the Wizardry
behind the waight the the rating they
had to hold less Capital Behind These
Investments and therefore they could
make a higher profit on them yeah I'll
just add to that I I agree with both
those I mean the um uh it has to do with
capital reir so for instance another
beautiful example is a Greek uh Greek
Sovereign bonds I think were also AAA uh
because uh uh for for banks to be able
to hold those uh but uh uh but but I do
think that the rating agencies were
really important in getting people to to
buy these uh to buy these things um and
you know one of the things related that
I just wanted to mention that it sort of
prompts is a lot of people have said
that securitization was uh a big part of
this and I for many reasons I don't
think that's right but one of the things
I think is funny about is yes home
mortgages were securitized but does
anybody know why Home Mortgage everybody
says well it's not like the old days in
which uh um Banks kept their mortgages
after they wrote them right you know we
got rid of that system the savings Al
loan Scandal you know what and the
problems you know what they decided when
basically interest rates went up and
mortgages were all like 4% and they had
to go out and raise Capital at 12% or
whatever the case was everybody said oh
the problem the government said oh the
problem is you're holding all these uh
these mortgages you need to get rid of
all of them so uh so that's what they
securization Dodd Frank has solved the
problem though DOD Frank says you need
to hold 5% of the mortgages they've got
them it's like baby bear's bed right
they've come up with exactly the right
amount they uh they say nobody knows
what 5% means we'll find that out
through the rul making process but uh
that kind of shows sort of the the
Washington mentality good thanks
next
yeah
set i'm cor from stering college and I
think um I have practiced real estate
for 10 years and has been teaching for
17 years 10 years at Texas A&M 7 years
in Sterling College and I think the
panel is extremely good with the
information but I disagree with uh the
information that the securitize uh uh
Securities are are not a problem it was
a big problem the CMO was a big problem
uh I think the uh Frank do and the uh
crisis uh the Frank do actually created
a big complicated bomb to kill a very
elusive
rat I think that's what it is elusive
Rats the problems they can't define the
problems
um rat
ratat uh if you look at the statistics
the uh us uh abstract uh from 2000 to
2006 the value of housing increased from
about 5 trillion to 10 trillion which is
huge increase and number two so that's
that's a problem number two the
derivatives was very very
complicated I had a a board member who
was involved in this business he said
that nobody understood what it is and
number three the subprime crisis loans
will make to people below 620 or 620 and
Below all right uh so to solve the
problem I don't think there's a need for
the Frank dot in my perspective there's
no need for Frank dot act in my
perspective and you can see this in
other countries I think the solution is
to adjust the loan to value so that the
investor has a skin on it that's number
one number two is is to uh raise the
credit score in such a way that uh again
people have a scheme in it and the third
thing is uh trying to understand and
manage the derivatives risks that a lot
of uh investors and even Bankers do not
understand and lastly I have a question
for you what do you think about a
quantitative the quantitative easing
will that create another of problems
that we
have may yeah may I comment first of all
I think I'm I basically agree with what
you said about the ways in which people
with low FICO scores uh were given
mortgages the ways in which uh people
were given uh mortgages with 1 and 2%
down payments with what was called no
docks you know what is the there's the
ninja no no no income no job that was
another great standard of giving people
mortgages and uh it was all as I said
the the capitalist systems doing in a
system of capitalism uh you know we we
want to bring back the banker we love to
hate U the the banker who would not give
you the mortgage because you didn't have
a job uh for long enough or because your
credit history wasn't good enough indeed
uh a number of years ago I was at uh
involved with the public broadcasting
system and they did a documentary in the
1970s in which they invade against that
Banker we love to hate Bankers were not
giving enough people mortgages uh they
they were being very cruel uh to uh to
people who they didn't think were credit
worthy uh and uh that was a big problem
now of course we hate another kind of
Banker uh the crony capitalist Banker
who is a creature of the government
because again only the government can do
that the profit and loss system is never
going to do that now of course you're
right that we what we need to do is is
restore character credit and quality
that that those are actually standards
there was a certain Pride uh among uh uh
credit analysts in mortgages uh who did
uh evaluate people properly and of
course they want you want to give a
mortgage this is what you do for living
uh it's a profitable business uh it's
it's a it is a collateralized loan but
you want to do it prudently and when but
when the government was uh when Clinton
and and and Barney Frank were pounding
on on on the system uh to On and On
Fanny and Freddy to buy mortgages uh
that of of PE with people that were
given to people far below the median
income that's what inevitably happen now
when you mention uh uh
securitization there's no question it is
a little bit of a puzzle as to whether
we would have had securitization in this
market if uh the government had not been
involved certainly Fanny and Freddy were
a big engine of securitization and
certainly the the the as uh as Todd was
saying the uh the savings and loan was a
reaction to it but uh there's no I don't
know if you you as an experienced person
in business would necessarily say that
derivatives are always bad I know Warren
Buffett famously talked about how what
derivatives were weapons of mass
destruction we just heard from such a
weapon I guess I don't know if that was
uh but Warren Warren Buffett was a guy
who actually bought derivatives you know
options and Futures are derivatives I I
do would suggest to you that to object
to uh to to securitization
securitization obviously has its good
points and it bad points there is there
is a a very nice idea that that if
you're that that that if you take on the
mortgage you're evaluating the customers
you know that person a little bit better
than anybody else does that that idea of
the of It's a Wonderful Life where you
know you're giving to the people you
know and love that's a great model but
certainly in a healthy Market it's
possible for to evaluate to bring in
even more Capital with secur a there's
nothing necessarily wrong with it it in
a way to object to derivatives is really
just a matter of shooting the messenger
uh and then you asked a larger question
about quantitative easing which is a is
a massive uh uh point I personally don't
believe I believe that qu dative easing
has done very little just to make a
simple assertion uh I believe that I
mean think think of it this way what are
they what is the government really doing
it's buying bonds uh in order with
printed money in order to keep uh the
interest rate low um in order to drive
bond prices up and keep the interest
rate low um think of it another way
let's say the government had a different
kind of qu quantitative easing let's say
it was buying uh stocks let's say it it
was it was moving massive amounts of
money into the stock market in order to
push prices up I I would think probably
we'd all agree that its initial impact
uh of doing so would be to pull prices
up but then ultimately wouldn't the
fundamentals rule if if if if companies
aren't really making profits wouldn't uh
uh or they are making some profits would
the the stock market eventually sort of
level itself and begin to reflect uh
real fundamentals eventually the stock
market does reflect fundamentals and so
I would suggest you that by analogy
really what the government because banki
and Greenspan and the rest of them just
want to be in the front of the Limelight
doing something getting involved with
something uh they had they brought about
this this quantitative easing uh uh of
of buying Bonds in order to to push down
interest rates I don't know if it's
having much of an effect I do think that
the unwinding of it is probably going to
be somewhat destabilizing but we didn't
come to talk about quantitative easing
and I shouldn't perhaps have gotten into
it I hope that I more or less answered
your questions from my standpoint I hand
it over to my colleagues to pick it up
sorry who have 30 seconds oh sorry
that's fine Nicole yeah yes I I agree
that securitization it securitization
introduced a new risk securitization
introduced Equity risk into long-term
Bond markets and that is not a good
thing the idea behind this approach
which is not novel we've been
securitizing things for 45 years and
this was a a fanny Freddy Innovation
along with Wall Street firms was you
instead of an investor Lending money for
a mortgage keeping it on the books for
30 years you could package up hundreds
of thousands of mortgages into one
security the security was like a stock
it was Liquid if you got tired of this
mortgage you didn't have to wait 30
years you could sell this investment of
mortgages to another investor that
moment and at the price that you were
expecting well the problem is by making
mortgages into liquid Investments you
take the risk risk that they behave like
liquid Investments which is to become
illiquid sometimes the economy can stand
a drop in the stock market economy
withstood it in 1987 and many times
before and after that the economy cannot
withstand the same type of precipitous
drop in the long-term credit markets you
can't have one day where everyone wants
to buy mortgages and one day where
everyone wants to sell them and so this
introduces another risk of bailouts
because you've in reduced volatility
into this market and the answer probably
does go back to the capital requirements
you can't take treat Banks differently
then you treat another type of investor
have a lot of capital Behind these
things and also behind the mortgages
that are are behind these things uh
quantitative easing is a bad idea and
let me introduce one other thing because
we hear a lot about the issue of
encouraging home ownership among people
people with low credit ratings or people
with low incomes and I just want to
remind people that well that is true the
problem that grew up grew up because it
is a middle class entitlement and it is
largely on a nationwide basis in upper
middle class entitlements New York
California Washington the rest of the
Northeast relatively affluent Americans
have gotten this notion that the value
of their home should increase every year
above inflation and above population
they have put all of their money and
much of other people's money into this
asset it would be easy to fix this
problem if it was a poverty problem it
is not easy because it is a middle class
entitlement just like social well
Medicare more than Social Security and
other middle class entitlements that are
hard to get rid of people expect a cheap
mortgage they've expected a cheap
mortgage since the early days or the uh
well the the middle days of the Reagan
Administration and they're going to be
very upset when they when and if they
learn this is not something that the
government should provide okay give Todd
one minute I'm gonna be up here with a
hook if he goes longer one minute um I
just want to comment on one last thing
which is on um there with with respect
to Consumers uh um The Narrative that
came out of Dodd Frank is that there
were all these hapless consumers who got
screwed by the Banks right that we sort
of know that whole thing the sort of
borrower victim sort of narrative but
next is this whole other view that uh
that Jee was describing which is that if
I make you an if I'm a bank I make you
an interest only mortgage with nothing
down and your house goes down in value
by $50,000 and you walk away from that
loan that's probably the best investment
you're going to ever make in your life
right you're just rationally responding
to incentives and what we know is the
most foreclosures were that foreclosures
have been caused by people whose homes
were underwater sure there were people
who got def fraud and that sort of thing
but a lot of foreclosures are caused by
people's homes were underwater now if
you ran respond to incentives whatever
that is it's not a consumer protection
problem it's not you being a victim
right and what we've done is we've
created a whole edifice based on the
idea that people are victims when in
fact many of these people were not
victims and we're creating a whole set
of problems moral hazard problems and
all kind of uh problems by by buying
into that mentality uh in our
regulation thank you Todd
good
[Applause]
yeah
and I thank our panelists Jean Nicole
and Todd for Illuminating a complicated
Bill thank
you